hi there steve here steve kaufman to
talk about languages and today i want to
talk about dictionaries all right
and uh
basically the reason i want to talk
about dictionaries is because i was
thinking about this person who asked me
to do a video about the word get
and i thought you know you can look up
the word get in the dictionary and you
get you get
eight or nine different definitions you
know
and then some phrasal verbs with some
further meanings and you can read that
close the dictionary and you won't
remember much of what was there that's
sort of the reality of dictionaries now
i am a sucker for dictionaries and i
want to show you my collection i just
went and grabbed a few here so
i don't know
vietnamese before i went to vietnam i
got this phrase books and dictionary
spent six days in vietnam i came away
able to use one word come on which means
thank you nothing else stuck zero this
was essentially useless
same for hebrew nothing stuck nothing
nothing except what i learned through
listening and reading on link okay but i
have okay i have bought so many
dictionaries most of which i never read
but it's very tempting you know uh
chesco anglicky mluvnik
chesko anglisky slovnik
uh you know japanese english dictionary
what do we got here english japanese
dictionary okay
uh from when i lived in japan
english korean korean english dictionary
english chinese pronouncing dictionary
essential arabic vocabulary
uh you know
sentango korean
handbook of korean vocabulary
uh tuttle lerner's korean english
dictionary
oxford the russian dictionary here's a
german one grundpod shots russia
what else we got oxford starter
dictionary
it just goes on and on and i've hardly
used anyone any of them the only one i
used was this one here which is used
because i lived in japan for nine years
and it has this one has the great
advantage that the
um you can look them up in the roman
alphabet so you hear a word i live in
japan i hear things i can look them up
and
sometimes find something
i can find the meaning for something
that i've been that i've heard and i
want to know the meaning of
but but the temptation with the
dictionary is that
somehow you think that you know
in this dictionary there's a bunch of
words and meaning
and if i read this that all of that is
going to enter my brain
but it doesn't happen that way
and so
the dictionary has this great promise of
enabling you to somehow shortcut the
learning process by gaining all these
words and your vocabulary is going to
expand but in fact
you need like where i learn is from what
you see behind me books cds listening
reading letting the brain get used to
the language and the sort of
you know
hitting a certain word and a meaning
no sooner you close the dictionary then
you've forgotten what was there
uh even when there is a meaning so often
you know if you look up the word get
there's eight meanings
so which meaning
are you going to take away from that if
if i'm reading
and say on link where we have online
dictionaries which by the way is a big
improvement
um sometimes there are four or five
meanings and sometimes they're totally
unrelated meanings
so i take from that a very vague sense
of what the word means
but it doesn't bother me because i know
that as i continue to come across this
word in different contexts
gradually
the range of meaning of that word and
the range or the particular
sense of that word that applies to a
given context
all of that is gradually going to become
clearer but it'll become clearer only if
i do enough reading and listening so
that i encounter it in different
contexts together with different words
and that way i acquire a sense of the
language
furthermore dictionaries
and and even in terms of learning the
language those purists who say we should
only speak the target language and the
dictionary should be monolingual
dictionary i don't agree with that at
all
you want to get in and out of the
dictionary as fast as you can to get a
bit of a hint of the meaning you don't
want to spend all kinds of time trying
to struggle through a mean a description
of the meaning in the target language
where you encounter more words that you
don't know and you come away without any
sense of what the meaning of the word is
you want to get a quick hint go back to
your context it's the context that's
going to give you the meaning
and therefore
a bilingual dictionary where one of the
languages is your native language or a
language you know very very well is much
sharper much quicker much more effective
than a monolingual dictionary uh
just as with my japanese if i were to
try and look up a word in my japanese
dictionary
using
uh
you know hiragana or kanji and it
becomes more complicated it's the same
with chinese dictionaries if you have a
chinese dictionary
i would only use one that is based on
pinyin so that you can go in there based
on the phonetics of the word
when we started with chinese we had to
you know
figure the the words in the dictionary
were divided up based on word count like
a stroke count
so you know once all the words that had
all the characters that had like three
strokes four strokes five took forever
to find it and you're going to forget it
anyway so that the quicker you're in and
out the better
and nowadays of course the dictionary
that i use the most is google translate
i have it on my i have a bunch of
dictionaries
on my iphone but the only one i ever use
is google translate
and
so if i have a word that i've come
across whenever i put it in there i got
the meaning gone i probably forget it
again but it satisfies and that's the
main role of a dictionary and that's why
the sort of online dictionary is so good
because it satisfies your immediate need
to get a sense of what this word might
mean so even though you may forget it it
satisfies that need right now in a given
context to get some
sense of what the meaning might be
very often especially for example in
learning korean you're disappointed
because the dictionary
for whatever reason the korean
you know there's a range of possible
meanings or it doesn't quite match the
context and yet still that's all you
have to go on
as you work your way through
this content and eventually it's the
context that teaches you so
the conclusion is the dictionary is very
tempting
uh you think it's a great source of
knowledge of words uh you might want to
keep a copy you know right by the toilet
it's a good where you have to sit and
you know you can
you have this sense that you're learning
something it's interesting actually it's
interesting it's it's interesting it's
like reading grammar rules it's
interesting you're reading it yet you
can't retain it very well you only
retain it through
the listening and reading so the
dictionary you do need it because as
you're working your way through content
okay there's a bunch of words you don't
know you have to get a sense of
roughly what that word might mean how it
ties into the rest of what you're
reading so you want to be in and out of
that dictionary as quickly as you can
and that's why i tend to do my reading
until i'm very good in the language i do
my reading on my ipad where i have
access to online dictionaries and and
furthermore if i'm on link i can look it
up and save it to a database i can
possibly review it later on and that way
the dictionary is is a minor
part of my
basically
input based learning strategy it's no
more than that but dictionaries are
tempting uh i don't buy them as much now
because i i find them quite useless but
i have
bought a lot as i showed you and there's
lots more here but i'm not going to show
you them
thank you thanks for listening bye for
now and i look forward to your comments
[Music]
you